if I had to make £100,000 as quick as
possible from scratch here is what I
would do the fastest way to make
£100,000 is definitely in the property
industry because in property 100 Grand
is not really that much money if you're
selling lemonade at lemonade stands
you're going have to sell a hell of a
lot of lemonade to make £100,000 and
it's not going to happen fast whereas in
property properties fluctuate in price
they go up and down like making 100
Grand in property is not a massive deal
you know I see houses in London all the
time they'll be bought for a million and
then sold for 1.1 million straight away
without even doing any work just because
they happened to be it was bought cheap
because it was a motivated seller and
then they sat on it and sold it three
months later so 100 Grand is not a lot
of money in property the problem is
speed and the issue is going to be
starting from scratch with no money so
what I would do is firstly I would go
out and I would start finding lucrative
deals in London because London's where
the expensive properties are there's a
lot of opportunities in London I'd be
going to auctions getting in with
auctioneers and I'd be finding good
property investment opportunities in
London now I got no money cuz I'm
starting from scratch but if I found
something that was really good
opportunity motivated seller and they
wanted to sell quickly I could then pass
that on to an investor and I could
charge for my time now typically you're
going to get around about 2% commission
2% finders fee when you do that so if
the house is a million you can make 20
20 grand in a finders fee I'd start by
doing that just to get the pot growing a
little bit and to get myself on the end
but to make a 100 Grand I think the big
money would come by actually buying a
property myself and I would do this I I
would partner with somebody so I'd
partner with someone that's got money
and wants to snowball it and I'd say let
me live in the house oversee the refurb
and do absolutely everything and all I
want is 50% not of the house I don't
care about owning that you own the house
I want 50% of the uplift so in other
words you find a house million pound
house in London run down you oversee it
manage it do all the transactions but
don't own it it's bought for A Million
by an investor who you found or you've
partnered with the investor owns the
house you then do it up for as cheap as
possible maybe it cost you £100,000 but
again it's not your money cuz you don't
own the house but then you bought it for
a million you spent 100 Grand on it
you've pushed the value up by 200 Grand
now it's worth 1.3 million but you
agreed with the investor that you're
going to get 50% of the uplift so you've
made £200,000 increas in value on the
property and you've got a contract in
place with the investor to say you're
going to get 50% of the uplift I think
that'll probably be the fastest way to
make 100 Grand from scratch it's very
doable to do that as well because now I
haven't got the time to be living in
houses and doing all all of that stuff
but I have got a lot of money I've been
in property for 15 years I've done over
500 deals I've just last week signed a a
contract with somebody where I said
exactly that I said I'll put the money
in we've just bought a hotel big hotel
I've said I'll put the money in you
don't own the property I own the
property but I've partnered with
somebody and I've said I want you to
oversee all the works I want you to live
in the hotel and it's it's probably
going to cost about £400,000 to do the
property up and then I've said whatever
the new value is whatever the increase
is I'll give you 50% in cash of the
uplift so from their point of view I
mean they found the deal they it's a
partnership they're going to make more
than 100 Grand from scratch in like six
months so if I was starting again from
scratch I just do what they're doing I'm
facilitate it's interesting CU sometimes
people say to me Samuel you make
property investing look too easy Samuel
just said sells people dreams I don't
sell people dreams they come to me with
the dreams I write the checks so if I
was starting again from scratch I'd find
someone like
me I'd find Samuel lead's equivalent
someone who's got money that is
aggressively wanting to build their
portfolio but lacks one thing and that's
an infinite amount of time and being
Omni presentent and i' say look you got
money you're one person you got money
let me find a deal I'll find a banging
deal motivated seller will buy it cheap
you put the money in in and then I'll
oversee it oversee the builders cuz that
takes time man overseeing Builders I'll
oversee it and then we'll spend as
little as we can and then we'll get a
new value and the profit that we've made
together will split 50/50 you give me
the half of the money but then you keep
the asset I think if I was doing that
from scratch I'd be pretty successful so
if I was trying to make 100 Grand fast
as possible from scratch that's what I
do but I want to know what would you do
let me know in the comments also if you
want to spend a day with me you want to
get to know me start doing business I've
got an incredible program coming up it's
called the property investors crash
course where I'm going to be teaching
all of the fundamental strategies in
property and condensing everything I
know into one day and also having an
opportunity for me to just get to know
people there's going to be future
business done 100% if you want to come
spend a day with me I'm going to be in
Manchester birmingam London I'll leave a
link in the description where you can
choose your best time and location come
meet me spend a day together let's do
business thanks for watching I'll see
you there Link in description